Hello, Dr. Kevin Connors with your man bird me into the day.
Today we're going to talk about cancer and sugar.
I have a confession to make.
I love sugar.
Who doesn't love sugar?
I remember when I was a little kid.
My dad used to feed me a little packet of sugar.
We were at a restaurant, which wasn't very often.
But he thought he was being a really good dad.
I put a little packet of sugar on a spoon and give it to me.
I want him to say, dick!
Don't do that.
I loved it.
I thought my dad was great.
But he was creating an addiction in me, right?
Sugar is not bad for you.
It's not good for you and it feeds cancer.
So what does cancer again?
It's this rapidly replicating cell line.
So rapidly replicating cell lines have a huge metabolic demand.
They need fuel.
It's rapidly replicating that just doesn't do that for free.
It needs gasoline.
Cancer is fueled by glucose.
So that's why you look at a book.
It talks about limiting your glucose levels.
Limiting your carb levels.
So carbohydrates, everything you eat can be broken down to glucose.
But the things that are rapidly broken down to glucose are carbohydrates.
The things that are really rapidly broken down to glucose are simple carbohydrates.
And things that have what are called a high glycemic index.
Even potatoes.
Potatoes actually break down to glucose faster than table sugar does.
So your starchy vegetables and your sugars are things that you have to eliminate
when you have cancer.
Or you were just feeding the cancer.
So I know you crave these things but you have to limit those things.
Now I do know that using a nursing approach and you're juicing vegetables
that tends to be a lot of glucose.
But you're getting a lot of enzymes with it.
So when you're getting a lot of enzymes with it,
you're kind of counteracting that glucose balance.
So it's more than just limiting your carbs.
So we don't want to get that wrong.
But in our office, we test people on all the food.
So we want to know exactly what that person can't eat and can't eat because it's very important.
Because not all cancers are fed by the diet.
So we have patients that come in that are used to eating at McDonald's
and used to eating, you know, candy and cookies all day long.
And then we have patients that have just a fantastic diet.
And they typically want to go, why did I get cancer?
Well, sometimes it has less to do with your diet.
Everybody's completely different.
And even though in my book, I have a standard diet protocol.
That's just a standard diet protocol.
It's a good one to follow.
In general, cancer feeds is fed by glucose.
So it's a high metabolic demand.
It just gobbles up glucose.
So you've got to stay away from sugar.